[Music]
hi reject nation I'm Greg Alba
I'm John we are going to watch a trailer
for a movie that no matter what video we
put up everyone keeps asked us to check
out this trailer it's dead and by
everyone I mean the same 50 people so
this is just for you guys
requests Leslie stop blowing up her
comedy
this is a movie that John was really
excited for because he saw beyond the
black rainbow this movie's called Mandy
which already has amazing reviews on
Rotten Tomatoes because it premiered at
some festival did great and yeah Nicolas
Cage hell yeah Nicolas Winding Cage I
don't get a patron today shots it can't
mcknight though kent McKnight is our
beautiful handsome man from Australia
who I'm constantly sending pictures of
my genitals to oh me too and he never
sends back a smiley face emoji or the
eggplant in the yeah and I found him on
a dating site and he wouldn't even
message me back then yet he's pledged to
our patreon and I assume than anyone who
pledges to our patreon wants to have
some relations with us yeah that's why
you come out right why aren't you
getting relationally involved I mean
we're basically prostitutes that's why
you pledged yeah Kent come on dude I
mean I'm willing to fly to Australia hop
in a kangaroo over to your apartment
that's gonna go well for you just so I
could Pao to you sexy things with you
yeah and I'll meet you halfway in like
you Europe or something cuz I want to
give you the man D is that like a Dundee
and - letter da Mandy cuz the movies
called Mandy and and the man the D is
for dick and I I see what you did Oh oh
shiz but yeah I can't I want to make you
feel can't make tight hahahaha just keep
getting better oh yeah anyway I'm glad
you're healing from the surgery you had
as a picture of that a sailor said Mandy
[Music]
shut up shorter on spectravision that's
right
that's a love story that's why you guys
wanted us to watch
[Music]
[Music]
cultish vibes here yeah
[Music]
fool
I think God's name is going on
[Music]
oh no that's good to hear whoa Mack
you think awesome in love I'll show you
love
where is your bread
[Music]
Wow
whoa chainsaw fight that's like that
that which there's a Texas Chainsaw
sequel with a gigantic chainsaw like
that that's what it's cool what's this
director's name
Pano's cosmatos who's the son of George
P cosmatos who's pretty prolific
Hollywood director it's pretty cool to
see that his visual aesthetic because I
remember the trailer for be on the black
frame I didn't actually catch it and
that's a much more abstract kind of
material yeah the visual style is still
pretty similar here except with a plot
you can actually follow so what I gather
is he falls in love with a girl named
Mandy manis kidnapped by this cult they
do some horrendous things he goes he
breaks out of the cage rage cage rage
cage situation like that calls for a
rage cage for a ridiculous Nicolas Cage
yeah
tormented soul who is on a rage ramp in
I feel like this is the movie for him
now yeah it looks cool looks disturbing
looks looks hypnotic and strange and
unsettling yeah and it still has like
what I saw beyond the black rainbow
footage that eighties sort of horror
metal vibe about it yeah more 70s yeah
yeah this one's got more metal in it to
me cuz beyond the black rainbow is very
simple
[Music]
he's got all that same expressive
lighting and stuff like that like those
scenes words like this is clearly
inspired by retro but it's also just
looks so punky and so gonzo and crazy
and it almost has like with like nay old
guy like something out of like a more
messed up madman actually exactly yeah
it's like a post-apocalyptic vibe but
it's not apocalyptic it looks like it
has some interesting practical designs
as well because you know you get some
other trippy animation that he likes to
sort of venture off into yeah but it
just looks like a hard film to maybe sit
through its like it'll be an onslaught
on the senses yeah Cage looks great he
does the cage looks awesome he's a wild
card now where I'm just like I don't
know what to expect whenever he shows up
in any place but I think this is the
place for him see Richard break yeah
okay to see to see just sounds gnarly to
me well some of these like striking
symmetrical images are really what I
mean you know like people said upgrade
is like a horror action movie and I'm
like kind of it's more like a sci-fi
thriller action film this feels horror
action yeah it's like both of these
genres are incredibly prevalent in this
trailer right and I mean they're
elements of horror and beyond the black
rainbow but that is a much more slow
burn sort of tense movie and when those
moments finally arise in a more
aggressive way it's towards the end so
this looks like this is gonna have a
good amount of punch yeah out and like I
can imagine that this might still be
really weird and abstract but I don't
think it's gonna be as deliberately
paced or anything like that yeah I mean
it's kind of hard to advertise this
person's films wrong you kind of got a
convey like no this is what got the
perfect style where it's like it's gonna
be hard to communicate exactly what's
gonna happen in one of his films but
you'll get the point yeah what kind of
stylistic journey you're about to go on
and I wondered two of they're gonna do
some like actual there's that one cell
they show that looks like a hand-drawn
animation sequence
I wonder if that's gonna figure in
somewhere I mean maybe there's some drug
stuff in here it's really honing in on
the alternate-dimension satanic vibe
which just seems so icky
he said with this he wanted to touch on
different elements of toxic masculinity
so see how that plays out I can see it
at work already
it looks very appealing that looks very
appealing thank you guys for constantly
telling us to watch it that was well
worth I'm excited not even a gory
trailer but you're like this feels like
a Mack from predators in it I even like
the actors they chose because they look
like they're from a 70s film yeah this
days look weirdly time it doesn't look
like they cast modern actors and try to
make them look like they're in a 70s
movie they look like actors from that
era
yeah and that was the thing that black
rainbow had going for it as well is it
really does just feel like a gem that
fell out of the wrong time period you
know well sweet guys Mandy this looks
awesome whose looks awesome what do you
guys think of it
if you like our reaction hit the like
button if you don't like our reaction
you can kiss our black ass subscribe to
the real rejects click that notification
bell check us out on patreon full-length
TV show reactions weekly q and A's music
video coverage click right here to get
stuck mine eyes dude dude